فمن اعتدى عليكم فاعتدوا عليه بمثل ما
اعتدى عليكم واتقوا الله واعلموا ان الله
مع المتقين صدق الله العظيم اقدم العدو
الامريكي البريطاني وفي اطار دعمه
لاستمرار الاجرام الاسرائيلي في غزه على
شن عدوان غاشم على الجمهوريه اليمنيه ب 33
غاره استهدفت العاصمه صنعاء ومحافظات
الحديده وتعز وحجه وصعده وقد ادت الغارات
الى ارتقاء خمسه شهداء واصابه سته اخرين
من ابناء قواتنا المسلحه يتحمل كامل
المسؤوليه عن عدوانه الاجرامي بحق شعبنا
اليمني ولن يمر دون عقاب ولن يمر دون رد
ودون عقاب ان القوات المسلحه اليمنيه لن
تتردد في استهداف مصادر التهديد وكافه
الاهداف الم عاديه في البر والبحر دفاعا
عن اليمن وسيادته
واستقلاله ان هذا العدوان الغاشم لن يثني
اليمن عن موقفه الداعم والمساند لمظلوم
الشعب الفلسطيني والقوات المسلحه اليمنيه
تؤكد استمرارها في منع السفن الاسرائيليه
او المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله من
الملاحه في البحرين العربي والاحمر والله
حسبنا ونعم الوكيل
نعم المولى ونعم النصير عاش اليمن حرا
عزيزا مستقلا والنصر لليمني ولكل احرار
الامه صنعاء الاول من رجب
1445 للهجره الموافق للثان عر من يناير
2024 صادر عن القوات المسلحه اليمنيه